what topic to just come under you tell
me think about it thank you
now I'll admit a little bit this could
be under databases because we all know
those spreadsheets are what kind of
database a flat file database okay but
the weather should a clue jeanne was
this one design why don't you think
about a a database of flat file database
and how has to be designed there's not
that much to design this just there's
just columns and rows and then there's
donna in fact if you wanted to design a
database with flat file you would
probably just make a dot a dictionary
that's as much design as there is ok but
if you're making a simple spreadsheet
based decision support system it can be
a little more interesting ok second
reason why you would think okay yeah pen
and paper this under decision support
systems is because you have to write
these in your exam if you have to show
people you understand how you can make a
decision support system just a simple
one but you don't get to bring computers
in to your exams at least not yeah so
pen and paper okay now what I encourage
you to do is if you have a sheet of
paper there I'll encourage you to turn
it landscape so that you can um because
what what will happen is you're gonna
have columns across the top and then
generally wider and you'd want them to
be and you won't be able to pick them
all across now I'm gonna do a super
super simple example with you and
demonstrate how all okay look we would
know how to make this spreadsheet if we
did it in Excel okay in fact I'm going
to do one that you have already made in
Excel but there's just like two or three
little things you need to be aware of
when you put it onto paper when you're
trying to put up your answer that will
be helpful to you okay so does anyone
remember when I ran you through
spreadsheet decision support systems
what was the first one that we designed
we did one together it was very simple
it had to do with weight right uh
specifically weight high body mass index
okay and we did all the columns we did
some sprint with some formulas and that
kind of thing so what I want to do is
rehearse
that decision support system because you
know what quite well and do it on paper
okay so what you think about in your
head okay what does this decision
support system have in it what kind of
data do we put in okay
so the first thing that I would write
for myself okay is all right what do i
what inputs do I need to provide okay so
what inputs do we need to provide if
we're making a decision support system
in a spreadsheet and I want BMI what am
I gonna need what was the first column
name okay so I'm gonna be a person right
not much used to me if I can work out
all these things but I don't know who
it's for
okay and then the BMI itself is
comprised of two different numbers what
are they
height and weight good okay now at this
stage what I'm doing is I'm trying to
structure this in my head so that when I
actually create the the spreadsheet and
put it out on my my landscape piece of
paper although where things are gonna go
and rather than you know if you start an
essay and you start the beginning and
then you start making point something
you're like I don't know where this is
going I don't know how it's gonna end
okay so we want to have a plan before we
actually now what comes out what's
produced at all of these inputs okay I'd
probably suggest two things I think that
we did on ours
what's the first thing the most obvious
one before he mentioned it the actual
BMI and then we also did something else
we use some fancy if statements and we
were creative and we said out of the BMI
we made our remember a recommendation or
even really simply just like a
classification like what kind of person
does your BMI tell us one okay are you
Harry are you normal like what are you
sir this is gonna be the user data that
comes in and we're gonna have to make
some formula some calculations to work
these out all right so now that we've
got that in our heads okay that's
probably enough let's actually start to
build this friendship
now one of the advantages of using Excel
to explain this to you at the beginning
is it everything's already set up you've
got your columns it comes to the top
you've got rows but since you're doing
this on kind of paper and you know in a
few months you'll get an example clip
and they'll just be you know a blank
sheet with just a few lines across it
okay you don't do everything from
scratch including these columns and rows
okay so the first thing I want is think
about this data in the start out and
what columns are we gonna put in here
okay so the first column and columns if
you remember they're they're all lay
this across the top that's going to be
the name right I'm going to struggle by
the way because this screen just doesn't
quite have the resolution that I'll need
but hopefully your landscape piece of
paper will do now the next column over
that's probably going to be high right
now I want to put that as centimeters
because that's actually that tends to be
the way that we say height and we need
to specify it in some format but when
you're actually working at the BMI you
can't use the height in centimeters
right what you have to do thank you
so I'm gonna make that the next column
variable okay now this is not a user
input but it's gonna be based off of
okay we also said we needed weight and
that needs to be kilograms okay do go
ahead and specify units that's important
and then I've got four columns and I
need two more corresponding to these
outputs right so I'm going to have this
fifth column as the actual beat high
right and this last column as
it's the kind of person who we've got so
far so good right now in a spreadsheet
this is all cells right this is a grid
and this ABCDEF is actually not part of
the spreadsheet it's just describing
what we've got here and then underneath
this is that sort of like our header row
these are all the fields so that's my
first row and then after that comes the
data right
I'm getting the idea all right now
there's the first half of the design
okay that's what it sort of looks like
when you put together the pen and paper
spreadsheet but we need to fill some
stuff in here right so the first thing I
want to distinguish between is that some
of this is usually in put it right and
some of it is calculated by the
spreadsheet okay so which parts are
which name higher centimeters and wait
that's all user provided information
okay so over these cells I'm going to
say user okay and if you have another
color you can use that but black will do
because that's what the scan office
anyway right so all of these cells I use
it don't skip this one
this column here is also use it on okay
so you can see which areas I've blocked
off right now what's left these one two
three columns okay